i
cierren los ojos cierren los ojos e
imagínense un país
un país con una ubicación geográfica
inigualable con una riqueza económica
con tratados con más de 46 países en el
mundo y con una estabilidad
macroeconómica que permita que la gente
que vive en él viva en libertad
viva en igualdad de oportunidad y viva
sobre todo en paz
si lo imaginan así ese país es méxico
mi nombre es carla mouse y ni soy
veracruzana nieta de inmigrantes de
escocia y españa y desde chiquitita
escuché siempre que méxico era el mejor
país para vivir
escuché de mis abuelos de mi familia que
méxico es un país donde llegas sin tener
nada con una mano adelante y otra atrás
y te oportunidad por la riqueza que
tiene porque sólo méxico encuentras a la
gente que te abre la casa y te hace
sentir como si estuvieras allí
hoy por hoy les voy a platicar la
historia de una niña que nació en
veracruz y que no solo tuvo que
confrontar ciertos retos pero tuvo que
tomar decisiones desde muy chiquita a
diferencia de lo que puedan pensar
gracias adiós crecí rodeada de una
familia maravillosa feliz patinando en
el malecón de veracruz pero lo que sí
tuve fue que tomar decisiones porque me
educaron así mis papás siempre me decían
desde los 5 años fíjate que si te subes
a un árbol te puedes caer pero si te
caes es tu decisión y cómo es tu
decisión tú sola te vas a levantar y tú
sola vas a caminar a ver quién te cura
era un poco difícil crecer con ese tipo
de educación dado que yo estaba en una
escuela de monjas donde las niñas se
caían y la mamá les ya tanto tope culpa
del tope que árbol tan tonto
imagínese que yo estoy ahí y de repente
volteaba a ver a mis amigas y decía algo
no está bien pero mi papá y mi mamá
siempre me decían decide cuando aprendas
a decidir en ese momento vas a ser
independiente y fue lo que empecé a
hacer desde muy chiquita pasó el tiempo
y tomaba decisiones así como de quieres
tener novio si pues agarra a tus
candidatos ponlos en una hoja de excel
prácticamente
fíjate qué quieres que tengan ellos qué
te gustaría que te pasa en la vida los
pones en una lista los nombres y de este
lado pones lo que quieres y el que tenga
más palomitas ese debe ser tu novio
como ven no me enfocaron mucho en el
romanticismo
sin saber elegir y también me enseñaron
que elegir decidir es igual a renunciar
cuando decidimos por algo renunciamos al
resto y eso fue lo que hice cuando tenía
16 años
mis papás tomaron la decisión hablaron
conmigo y me dijeron sabes que lo más
importante que te vamos a heredar es la
educación y me mandaron a estudiar a
boston entre estudiar a harvard y ahí
pasó a mi primer daño colateral que es
para mí un daño colateral un daño
colateral que es todo aquello que nos
pasa pero que no depende de nosotros y
como decimos en méxico ni teníamos vela
en el entierro
esta situación sucede por alguna cosa
externa pero sin duda cómo reaccionamos
a ella es la que nos hacen más fuertes o
nos hacen más débiles ya que nos hace
caminar o nos hace dos pasos para atrás
mi primer daño colateral estando
estudiando en harvard fue la devaluación
de 1994 que sin duda todos los que están
aquí la vivieron pero allá se vivió un
poco más difícil porque porque
obviamente al estar en una de las
universidades más caras y más buenas del
mundo pues mi papá un día me llama y me
dice carla el dólar se fue de 360 a 11
20 lo que equivale que hoy estoy pagando
tres hijas en harvard
y yo me quedé pensando y dije siempre he
pensado que valgo por 3
pero así mi papá me dijo pues sabes que
vas a tener que ayudarme entonces hice
lo que hace cualquier joven en eeuu en
europa que es me puse a cuidar niños
pasear perros ganaba un dineral paseando
perros pero a la hora de la hora me di
cuenta también de que si yo hubiera
estaba en veracruz
eso hubiera estado incorrecto eso no se
hubiera visto bien porque no está cool
que una niña de 17 años 18 años esté
paseando perros o cuidando niños y ese
es otro tema en méxico necesitamos hacer
que nuestros hijos salgan antes llegan a
los 30 años y siguen en la casa
esperando que la mamá le lleve la comida
o que los lleve a la escuela porque ya
están los hijos en la maestría
ahora después de todo esto pasó muy
rápido no regrese de boston y me dediqué
a trabajar a traer inversión extranjera
directa en veracruz fue una gran
oportunidad la realidad que el nombre de
la universidad habla mucho y conseguí el
mejor el mejor puesto que pude haber
tenido a los 19 años ya estaba
trabajando en bajar inversiones de 250
millones de dólares de inversión inicial
y así me fui hasta que llegué a
secretaria de turismo porque siempre
había querido ser secretaria de estado y
en eso mis papás me dijeron la maestría
ok entonces me fui a estudiar la
maestría de españa' y estando en españa'
decidí que podía hacer la maestría de la
especialidad ser secretario función
internacional en la asociación de europa
y empecé a hacer muchas cosas pero entre
ellas concursé para ser candidato para
segundo secretario de las américas de la
organización mundial de turismo
ahí tenía 22 años bueno estudie me
preparé de pase exámenes regresé a
méxico hablé con el presidente hablé con
los gabinetes y me dieron sus cartas de
recomendación regresé llegué presenté
exámenes pase y dijeron así agárrate
américa porque todos los programas se
van a méxico
pero qué quieren que pasó segundo daño
colateral el ataque terrorista en las
torres gemelas sabe yo en madrid
comiendo y de repente de un avión de
otro avión y en ese momento del mundo
cambio para todos en un cerrar abrir de
ojos cambió todo empezamos todos a
preguntarnos sobre seguridad la onu se
declaró en crisis y el protocolo de la
onu es que no cambian las plantillas y
se quedan los que ya estaban
como ven son daños colaterales son cosas
que no tienen que ver con lo que yo hice
porque yo pasé mis exámenes fui y tuve
las recomendaciones sin embargo decidí
que eso tenía que pasar y di gracias a
dios porque no estaba yo en las torres
gemelas porque siempre que ver como algo
peor para que no te sientas mal y de
repente dije va va para atrás y ahí va a
caer la para atrás me regreso a mexico
trabajo en consejo de promoción
turística llevó las relaciones públicas
del mercado directo en internet para
méxico norteamérica europa asia pero al
año y medio había algo que yo había
aprendido en españa' que estaba haciendo
la maestría que era el cabildeo entonces
empecé a pensar cómo podría yo reformar
leyes para beneficiar realmente a mi
país y abrí mi empresa es una empresa
donde hago ya traigo inversión
extranjera directa llevo cabildeo pero
lo más importante es que esa empresa hoy
tiene 16 años
y he trabajado para hacer reformas a
leyes importantes en mi país también he
bajado plantas para inversión extranjera
pero lo más padre es que cuando yo
estaba ya en el momento más fregón de mi
historia más exitoso profesionalmente mi
papá se enferma y le dan un mes porque
tiene cáncer en ese momento estaba yo
pues ya muy enamorada mi mamá dice que
es la venganza de moctezuma porque
regrese de españa con un mexicano
y entonces todo bien embarazada de tres
meses mi papá se enferma de cáncer y ahí
empieza todo es cuando empiezas a decir
qué pasa si esto si yo no estuviera
embarazada cómo hago que mi papá
encuentre una cura y voy por todo el
mundo y ahí entiendo que el cambio es la
única constante porque es la única
constante porque hay veces que nos
resistimos al cambio y pensamos que esto
simplemente porque cerramos los ojos no
va a pasar y la realidad es que lo que
hay que hacer es fluir y aceptar
cuestiones como las enfermedades como lo
que yo estaba viviendo en ese momento ya
se imaginan que pasó el tiempo y mi papá
pues estaba cada vez peor y mi bebé
estaba cada vez más grande
y entre los hospitales para ver cómo lo
podían curar y veía niñitos con tumores
en la cabeza y yo con un bebé en la
panza y sí pensé dije dios quiera que no
que mi hijo nazca sano entonces empieza
es como haber prioridades de la vida y
bueno nace mi hijo se muere mi papá no
la alcanzó a cargar se muere y en ese
momento yo paro la empresa me dedico a
mi hijo pero también después de la
experiencia de ver a tantos niños
enfermos con enfermedades terminales en
estos hospitales me metí a los
hospitales públicos en mexico a ver cómo
podría yo ayudar y ahí descubrí muchas
cosas entre ellas descubrí que no es lo
mismo un pobre enfermo que un enfermo
pobre
ahí me di cuenta que la pobreza es igual
la tragedia y también descubrí que yo
que tenía pues en ese momento la
posibilidad de llevar a mi papá los
mejores doctores te das cuenta que en
las comunidades y en las zonas más
pobres del país ni siquiera saben que
están enfermos los niños que se mueren
entonces empecé a trabajar durante 12
años en pediatría y ayudar a los niños y
tal y un momento en que decidí después
de pelearme con algunos doctores decidí
empezar a hablar con las mamás con las
señoras porque no te dejan hablar con
ellas para que no haya esa relación
sentimental y de repente camino por el
pasillo y me encuentro una mamá ahí y la
veo llorando pero llorando me acerco y
escucho que le está diciendo un bebé con
un casco muérete
en ese momento yo agarre dije deberías
estar pensando en un milagro deberías de
creer que tu hijo puede mejorar y se
voltea la señora imagínense una señora
muy pobre de una comunidad que venía de
la sierra
zongolica se voltea y me dice quiero que
se muera quiero que se muera porque
tengo meses y no se muere y mi esposo
violó a mi hija
y mi esposo violó a mi hija y lo repetí
o lo repetía y lo repetía y en ese
momento dije esto es increíble ya no es
la problemática del niño enfermo que se
está muriendo que la señora duerme en la
calle para poder ver a su hijo todos los
días que la problemática real es que el
resto de su familia está totalmente es
cobijada está en la calle le están
robando le sacan los órganos todo pasa
en méxico cuando hay pobreza por lo cual
pobreza es igual la tragedia
en ese momento ya estaba yo así
verdaderamente desesperada y dije que
hago
en el ínter obviamente se los voy a
contar en tres segundos pues me casé
tuve hijos y me divorcié
para que sea más rápida
y qué pasó decidí también regresar a ser
independiente libre porque vivimos en un
país donde el machismo pulula se corre
entre los mares de este país y cuando yo
decidí que quería trabajar que quería
hacer cosas que quería cambiar el mundo
y que quería cambiar a méxico pues
simplemente mi ex me dijo tú tienes que
estar con tus hijos y hubo un momento
donde me confrontaba con mis hijos y les
decía a mis hijos ya con 53 años a tu
mamá le interesa más tu trabajo que tú
ese tipo de situaciones fue cuando dije
sabes que papá ya se imaginan porque es
mi ex ahora qué es lo importante y
enfocándonos en lo que tengo que dar que
es una idea
está clarísimo que en méxico nos enseñan
a guardar silencio que méxico nos dicen
no lo cuentes porque hay muchos
envidiosos
pero la realidad es que yo soy el
resultado de que cuento todo lo que
quiero hacer comparto mis sueños hablo
con la gente y cuando ven ya son los
días ya somos 20 ya somos 30 en un
momento dado que es lo importante si
vamos a hacer las personas que estamos
haciendo nos vamos a equivocar igual yo
tomé decisiones igual de decisiones que
erróneas pero la peor decisión como bien
lo decía benjamin franklin es no hacer
nada
en este país yo he vivido 20 22 años en
las comunidades bajando inversión
llevando tal y lo único que he visto es
un mundo de mexicanos que pueden hacer
cosas y no hacen nada
ahora que necesitamos saber hoy cómo
estamos en méxico tenemos unas
comunidades en el centro y sur del país
que viven en pobreza y en pobreza
extrema
estas comunidades no es que no quieran
trabajar tras que decidieron vivir en la
pobreza estas comunidades nacieron ahí
y viven quizá enfrente de una planta de
una empresa y lo que ha pasado es que
durante años durante años han crecido
generaciones tras generaciones sin el
apoyo a menos cuando es el tren navideño
pero sin el apoyo de esas empresas hacia
ellos que necesitamos hacer hace unos
años cuando ya me volví como el monstruo
de la inversión y entonces ya le decía
el sillón pues aquí sí aquí no y ya con
esa confianza de empresas globales
decidí empezar a decir a ver tú estás
aquí tienes pobreza porque no le das
trabajo a esta gente porque cuando
abrimos una planta de repente me traes
500 argentinos o me traes a gente de
nuevo león chiapas
los empresarios con toda razón me
dijeron yo soy un corporativo
soy una empresa global no me puedo meter
en política pública ni educar a la gente
ni bla bla bla
crea mi fundación pensando en esto que
dicen eso mandela que la educación es el
arma más poderosa creó una fundación
fundación por mexico creamos un modelo
donde las empresas globales y nacionales
de la mano con la fundación abrimos un
aula por mexico y llevamos a educación
llevamos capacitación y le damos perfil
a la gente para que en 6 meses estén
trabajando en la planta imagines
empresas que méxico tienen 15 plantas 40
mil empleados y que sus empleados no
sean mexicanos pero además todavía que
estén ahí que la gente esté viviendo a
10 km que esa gente no tiene que comer y
entonces lo que pasa es que si hay una
erosión y una inseguridad en la zona
terrible entonces decidimos empezar a
trabajar con eso hoy lo que les puedo
decir es que estoy muy contenta de ver
como los empresarios se han sumado al
trabajo que estamos haciendo pero por
qué porque les damos
bajamos rotación si contratas a la gente
de la comunidad y le damos el perfil
bajo la rotación por qué porque no lo
tienes que traer ni de otro país ni de
otro estado nosotros estamos trabajando
con la vocación en méjico y nueve
sectores prioritarios económicos y en
eso se está el aeroespacial eléctrico
electrónico etcétera y cada estado de
este país sino una vocación tiene
inversión y tiene una cadena de
proveedores si no trabajas en la planta
podrías estar en la cadena de
proveeduría y eso es lo que importa
entonces estamos trabajando de manera
conjunta para generar ese capital humano
que queremos lograr en méxico queremos
paz queremos ese país que les dije
cuando cierran los ojos es ese méxico
que debemos de creer debemos dejar de
hablar mal de méxico hay países que
tienen intereses para que méxico le vaya
mal ya nosotros los mexicanos nos
interesa que a méxico le vaya bien es
por eso que hoy me permito compartir con
ustedes que justo cuando piensen que no
pueden hacer nada por mexico cuando vean
que digan pues vamos a esperar otros 5
años lo único que tienen que pensar es
que una persona normal veracruzana como
yo hoy por hoy 22 años después ha
ayudado a bajar 20 plantas de sectores
diferentes en el país tenemos 7 aulas a
un año y medio que está operando la
fundación tres ludotecas con niños
chiquitos de 3 a 12 años hijos de
jornaleros agrícolas para que aprendan
las letras que hablan 12 lenguas
reconstruimos cuatro escuelas en el
terremoto y además tengo dos hijos
si me preguntan si se puede claro que se
puede lo importante que es es que no
olviden que siempre como decía mi papá y
como decía mi mamá puede más el que
quiere que el que puede y con eso
ustedes solo tienen que entender que es
algo interno que permite que las cosas
funcionen
hoy estoy aquí yo espero que para el
2040 estén ustedes sus hijos sobrinos
hablando del país que es con el que
inicie esta plática muchas gracias
[Aplausos]